who is going to win the 2020 election
either way we are in trouble
uh because either either victor
will will make the culture war worse not
better right and the reason for that is
biden has completely bought into
identity politics
100 and he's allowing himself to be
guided in that way and
donald trump also has his version of
identity politics
uh and which is the sort of more sort of
nationalism style
version and he's not let's face it uh
particularly well
uh equipped to deal with this kind of
crisis right he
tends to inflame things rather than make
them better you know fundamentally
uh donald trump likes people who like
him and dislikes people who don't like
him
so and everyone knows this it comes back
to this this essential narcissism
watching those two debate was the one of
the most depressing things i've heard
i've ever seen neither of them are
equipped to be
president and um i just
i don't think either side is going to
quiet him down because if trump wins
then the social justice group will take
that as further evidence that they live
in a neo-fascist
society and if if if biden wins then i i
suppose
they will be emboldened to to to persist
with these kind of demands
such as the students that radha make and
to to reshape society
according to the principles of their
faith
uh so either way we are [ __ ]
have you got a prediction do you think
can you i know that it's not your
special
your special area but what do you think
i think biden is going to win i think um
i
i i for a long time i thought trump was
i'm sure that trump would have one where
not for coronavirus
i'm i'm crazy because the economy was
doing so well uh and because the
it just didn't seem as though
i i think though his handling of the
coronavirus
combined with this kind of general
fatigue
with his uh his behavior and the way
that he tweets he needs to get off
twitter you know if he wants very much
yeah it's um if if the election
was about trump versus if it was just a
personality contest on biden if that was
the competition on biden biden would
lose but sadly
trump continues to make it about himself
which i think is inherently dangerous
because his personality rubs people up
even his own support is the wrong way he
does i mean has no charisma whatsoever
but then
but then trump you know it's not let's
put it
delicately it's not states statesmanlike
is he you know
no one can have looked at the debate
that they had the other week yeah and
say that that was a presidential way to
conduct yourself
i wouldn't be able to vote for either of
them but luckily i'm not in that
position
of having to make a choice you're done
yeah no i
am i don't i think i think you're right
i think at the beginning of 2020 it
would have been
trump to continue um especially given
that
all of the the harbingers of the
apocalypse
that everyone had predicted were going
to occur in 2016
didn't happen and he did some good stuff
he did some good stuff with the middle
east like that was only this year i
think when when he
you know oh yeah i mean that's a major
deal that the the the
the left-wing media are not covering at
all they're staying well well
quite astonishing uh unbelievable but
yeah you know so all of the stuff that
was supposed to happen
didn't happen and the economy was doing
good and
i think it was was it black schooling
that he'd contributed more money to than
any other president ever including the
only black one
it's not about that anymore is it but
this has become the cultural election
and uh i'm afraid that's where we're at
[Music]